hello and welcome to a spectator tv
special i'm katie balls and i'm joined
by james forsythe and we're going to
talk about the first round of the tory
leadership contest that we just bad
witness to
james we've had some knockouts
yeah jeremy hunt the former uh health
secretary and former foreign secretary
who came second to boris johnson in 2019
is out i think his own analysis of why
he's out is actually right which is
essentially the tour leadership you get
one shot at it and i mean people were
the view that you know you can't really
go back to the membership and say you
didn't pick him in 2019 would you pick
him now i mean that's really probably
what did for jeremy hunt's campaign
along with the fact that tom tugan heart
you know the kind of young turk of the
one nation wing of the party kind of got
out earlier and in front of him uh and i
mean that's what did for him then uh
there is nadim zahawi the chancellor who
is also out i think if we'd done this
recording a four night or so ago i think
lots of people are talked up in the team
so harwi um
including myself he had a lot of
transferability it was the phrase that
people used about him which was the idea
he could pick up support from all sorts
of different wings of the party i think
ultimately what did for him was the
confusion of the end of boris johnson's
time in government remember that i'll
get my days the week wrong now but on a
tuesday night nadine zahawi accepted the
job of chancellor from boris johnson
then on wednesday night he went to see
boris johnson to say look i don't mean
this is going to work i don't think you
can stay on as prime minister there was
there he didn't resign that night and
there was some confusion because various
people were saying that we were signed
up to give a big speech on the economy
lining up some kind of immediate tax
cuts then on thursday morning the theme
song we published the letter which said
he's not resigning but he thought it was
time for johnson to go and i think that
that combination of events just left
colleagues kind of confused about uh
what nadeem sahib was thinking and just
it was just a
it's very it was very difficult to get
going
from there for him in this leadership
campaign so those two are the two to
drop out tonight and just to bring our
viewers up to speed obviously do you
send your questions because we're going
to come to them shortly um but you had
to get 30 nominations today to make it
through uh as we just discussed uh both
jeremy hunt nadine sahory failed to do
that the candidate he received the
highest number of uh nominations as
rishi sooner on 88
for the fairly closely behind by penny
moore did on 67
and then you had kerry badenock on 40
you have tom teugenhart and 37 and you
have sued a braverman on 33. um james
listening to those results and you've
got some questions about who is the
momentum but just looking at how the
vote is splitting
it feels when it comes to the right of
the party they're still to decide who
their candidate is going to be even if
there are tentative signs
more leaning towards this trust yeah so
liz trust got 50 votes uh but i think
it's very difficult for her to unite the
right whilst wealth raymond is still in
this contest which she will be tomorrow
and i think the tricky thing is that um
there are lots of people around swallow
britain who don't understand why she
should drop out of the contest in favor
of blizz trust you know so ella
braverman was a brexiteer he voted
against theresa may's deal um repeatedly
liz truss is a remainer he voted for it
and and and so even though liz trust has
got the backing of people like jacob
rees-mogg ian duncan smith you know
figure senior figures on the right of
the party i think there are still a lot
of of sweden brotherhood supporters who
were like well well why should she back
her um and so that that is kind of
continuing to be a an issue
um and so we wait to see now i think
what happens
next in this contest and it's very quick
because it is tomorrow there aren't
there aren't um days of mps mulling
their choices
it's another vote tomorrow night
um and i think that
the the challenge
for liz trust is you know she's at 50 um
but
how much of that so how we
hunt support can she pick up
and also
how much of that i think she wants to at
the very least keep her gap from kenny
babnock where it is i mean kevin may
knock has had a very good contest so far
it would be it would make life difficult
i think for liz trust if next time
around may not it was gaining slightly
on her
and so i think we see that i think that
is interesting i think that nadeem
zarway has said that he will not endorse
anyone in this contest i think i think
that you know i think i think obviously
everyone would have liked his
endorsement but i think that that is an
interesting sign as well i think of the
fact that no one can quite tell where
this is going
um
though as you discussed nadine saw his
endorsement and boris johnson was quite
short-lived last week so
um now let's go to some of the questions
that we have so one question here um we
can both answer them in a snappy and
short way and all right
so
that we'll get a few more questions uh
who has the momentum now
i think from today my take is penny
morden has the momentum um in the sense
that richie nick is the front runner but
he's been established as that and
therefore we've had with this membership
polling coming out today which has shown
penny morden
uh you got paul mirroring to a degree
what the con home poll said earlier this
week suggesting she would fare well
against nearly all candidates in in a
playoff um it does for that combined
with the fact that her public number of
backers was lower than the number that
she came out for today it does feel as
though penny wardens is the person that
everyone's talking about not just if
she's having a party tonight yeah i
think that she she is obviously got six
seven was a good set of numbers for her
i think 88 was above path for rasheed i
mean that was kind of more than he
needed to establish himself as that and
i think that i think the gap between
penny morgan and liz trust was slightly
bigger than i was expecting um
and so i think we wait to see now
who what what the numbers are tomorrow
where does it go who who's got it
building for them um and i think the
other thing that is clear is this is a
very very fluid contest um
and i think that
things such as these tv debates that are
coming up in the next few days
and the first few hustings are with the
membership round are really going to
matter i think this is going to become a
very i mean it was always an
unpredictable contest but i think it is
a particularly unpredictable contest now
because there is this question here can
you liz trust unite the right to make
our way through to the final two um how
does penny morton cope with everyone now
saying ah right penny morton is this
morning you were calling you rightly
calling penguin a dark horse candidate
she has now in the in the course of a
day
um shifted from dark horse to kind of
you know uh to kind of um to i think the
favorite in the betty markets and so i
mean this is the kind of question of how
does all this pan out it is very
unpredictable
um we're just going to apologize now
because in the background not sure you
can see it but james what do we have we
have a marching band about to accompany
us and bringing the results
so we're going to bring the microphone
closer i'm being nodded at okay so
here's a question um on penny morden and
given penny mordent it's almost seen as
a military candidate well maybe but you
know that sense perhaps this music is
appropriate and where are penny mordance
votes coming from i think what is
important here is effectively
we keep talking about the candidates on
the right of the party i think what can
be a bit confusing as well where are
penny morgan's votes coming from is she
a one nation tory she was a brexiteer
she campaigned for that um so where is
her base
so i think penny morton one of the
things that the other camps have had
difficulty getting a handle on i feel
like a very old-school bbc announcer the
microphone very close like this i mean
one of the things that the other
campaigns have had is that you know she
slightly defines easy ideological
characterization so she is a brexiteer
but she's also the person who stood at
the spatchbox and said uh trans men and
men and trans women are women which is
not a position that many members of the
eerg take for example
no no indeed
but so so she she has a mixture of
positions i also think that the other
thing penny morton is mordant is a thing
that we can you can easily forget in
contests like this
she has been an mp for a fair while and
she has a lot of friends she's put a lot
of effort into cultivating people
and so i think that that is another
element of this contest which is you
know that that social element those
bonds of friendship that people people
form the view that someone's got uh you
know the the they're gonna back someone
because they trust them and they know
them personally
now
next question is from simon collis how
do you expect the eliminated votes to be
distributed amongst the remaining
candidates um i think for now it's safe
for me to put that down
um
oh no okay that's i'll keep my prop and
so tonight we'll be expecting because
james as you say this is so fast they're
back tomorrow having to vote dude
there'll be lots of frantic phone calls
trying to win over the supporters i mean
not all of someone's supporters are
going to go cohesively to one place
yeah i don't in these contests you can't
move your mps around like pieces on a
chessboard and say right i'm coming with
me and all my supporters i mean i think
raymond christie could do that but i
don't think many other um uh people can
yes um uh and so i think that i think
the question is where do they go
um
and i think i think again it is it is
not easy to tell so i think the hunt
support the tougan heartlock will be
very keen to get quite a good chunk of
those because they are you know they
were those were the two one nation
candidates i i think that some of those
will go through soon at because i think
some of those
ain't some of the reason that those
people were backing uh jeremy hunt over
tom teugenhart was uh you know a viewer
you had to have ministerial experience
to become prime minister
um but zaharwe but well as a hobby votes
go again is interesting because he was
very much a kind of centrist candidate
in this race and so you can almost
imagine them going you can you would not
be surprised to see them splitting
around among almost all the candidates i
mean i don't mean
many of them are going to get as well
abroad because um because
because you know she represents a
particular type of uh brexiteer tory of
which i don't think zaha we have many um
in his column
but i think all the other candidates
will think that they have a chance of
getting some of those sahabi voters
uh now we have another question which is
rishi sunex still needs another 30
breaks to secure a place in the final
round is there a chance he doesn't get
them i think my take on that is
he's clearly has the most votes for now
and we've got to see where they fold i
think it's interesting what you're
saying james which is some of the jeremy
hunt votes could go to rishi sunag
because if you're looking at some of the
pledges by lots of these candidates they
will be in uh very low tax and low tax
now um immediate tax cutting which
actually puts them
in opposition in a way to what ritchie
sunic has been saying which is don't
believe in fairy tales we are going to
cut taxes but we have to wait which i
thought might put some limits on
some mps backing one candidate and then
going to someone saying something a
little bit different and i think that
it's also interesting when you look at
the candidates on the right because
there's lots of talk tonight about how
they need to rally around one um but
christopher hope from the telegraph is
saying they plan to do that and then
they're going to storm rishi sunac and
implying maybe you could knock him off
um but i wonder if it might be a more
fruitful game than to try and uh push
penny off in in terms of where the
numbers are coming from what do you
think
i i think there is an interesting
question here which is i think that you
can see look i don't think anyone could
sit here and say oh xyz person is
certain to get 120 votes to get through
to the final round i don't know
but i also think you could you can see
what um
my math is limited so we need 32 more
votes i mean you can see where those 32
more votes might come from um i think
the question for
the question of the liz trust is you
know how much is she now in competition
with penny bordened i think quite a lot
because you know i i think there will be
penny morton is kind of yes she's not
put as much emphasis on immediate tax
cuts as liz trust has but you know but
but i think there are some similarities
in between the kind of mourn and trust
offer
um i always think bennymoon is an
interesting question in terms of her
relationship to the boris johnson
government because she was a minister in
it but she was never in the cabinet in
it and
uh there was a lot of puzzlement at
westminster about why she never resigned
from the borrower's johnson government
even when kind of you know we were up to
what what how many resolutions did he
get 250 odd or something she she wasn't
one of them i i mean you see perhaps
tonight the wisdom of that but she has
not attracted the ire of boris johnson's
supporters in the way that those
candidates who quit
did
um and and maybe that is making it
slightly easier for the fact that she
chose to just you know sit tight um and
keep her head down at the department of
international trade now we've got two
questions we're going to end on i'll
take one you'll take the other james and
then we're going to bid you for a while
to her next session and so
i'll take the million dollar question
from
chris which is how does kemi win and
then james we're going to come to you
which is if penny won what do you think
her cabinet would look like
um how does kemi win i mean i think if
you just look at the
polling and also i would say definitely
in terms of our website and our writers
both in the magazine and online it feels
as though kemmie bainock is a candidate
who is exciting spectator writers such
as rob liddle and others the most there
seems to be a lot of interest in reading
articles about her i would say if you're
writing something like kenny baden arc
if you're ranked
yeah it there's there's an immediate
audience for that
and
and
therefore i think she ultimately just
needs to convince the others that she is
the best candidate for the right of the
party if she can get the mp backers i
think in a final two things would get
very very unpredictable now i think we
have to caveat that which is effectively
because there's less known about these
candidates there is a higher risk that
they blow up or something goes wrong or
they actually decide they don't like the
level of scrutiny that comes with going
for the top job and if you think about
having andrea ledson in
the 2016 leadership contest made the
final two a few rookie errors then all
through that interview um with the times
uh where she was reported as uh you know
bringing up the fact that theresa may
didn't have children and it led to her
bearing out so it can be very
unpredictable but i do think uh speaking
to mps even some of them don't want kemi
t not to be prime minister some who do i
think what they can all agree on is if
she got to the final two is that she
convinced her mps which i think went out
as a tall ask and then she would be a
very tricky candidate for whoever is
facing her um james going over to you
now for penny's potential cabinet well i
think you can you can see at her kind of
campaign launch a campaign team who's
important to her george freeman i think
is a kind of big you know policy
influence on her um he asked a question
the other day and asked commons about a
particular cabinet job that he would
like to see created uh kind of in charge
of business research
i think it's fair to say that he might
have his
eyes on that he also sent an intriguing
tweet suggesting that um tom tukenhalt
would make a very good foreign secretary
which i think was a fairly public play
from the morden campaign um andrea led
some introduced uh penny morden today
and you know she's been business
secretary and you know you can imagine
her maybe as as a chancellor of any
modern administration so i i think you
know but those those are the kind of
things that you you can see happening
and i think this is this is an
interesting question i think i think
that um uh
i think sean's question
will be asked a lot more by people in
the coming days because you know there
is a kind of you know very penny morgan
has written this book about what how
kind of policy plan is for britain
but you know and i think i think there
will be lots of people kind of combing
over it in the next few days you know to
try and work out you know what is
modernism
and with that thank you very much for
watching thank you for joining us we
will be back with more of these as the
contest goes on and we will see you then